You can also this to call methods. Here's an example. I created another method,
makeMutualFriend, in the Person class. Because a lot of the time when I make a
friend with someone else, they also make friends with me. In the method, I add
someone else as a friend and then they add me. This is an example of calling
one method inside of another method. Here I call addFriend on the current
object from inside the makeMutualFriend method. I also call addFriend on the
front parameter until it add this object as a friend. In the first method
called the impressive parameter Is this object. It's the same as the implicit
parameter of makeMutualFriend call. In the second method call the implicit
parameter is the friend object. If I remove this dot in front of addFriend
here, we would now say that this method call is without an implicit parameter.
A method call without an implicit parameter is applied to the same object, so
addFriend, friend is the same as this.addFriend, friend. Which way you write it
is up to individual preference. I'm using the this reference in other more
interesting place here. I'm using it to pass the current object in as a
parameter, so when addFriend is called on a friend, It'll know who to add.